here we go i definitely think that it's
going to become one of those things that
just happens at universities
of submitting your vaccination record i
know of a lot of people who stayed home
for first and second semester but i
think
a lot of them are planning to come to
campus in the fall a growing number of
colleges around the country will require
students get vaccinated before returning
to campus in the fall
that means a lot more in-person events
in-person
activities and classes of course
masks and social distancing may still be
a part of campus life
but certainly more classes will be
happening inside the classroom that they
have
this year but the mandates are stirring
up controversy about the legality
and whether colleges can make
vaccinations a condition of attendance
will the requirements help campus return
to some semblance of normal in the fall
or will there be legal setbacks
[Music]
for northeastern a private university in
boston
the school says herd immunity is the
best path to return its 18 000
undergraduates to fully in-person
classes
the magic of an undergraduate degree is
that you're close to your friends
and you're close to your classmates and
you learn together but that same thing
that makes it so rich and interesting
does allow the virus to spread
northeastern administrator
michael armini believes the school is on
solid legal ground with the requirements
so we're going to require the covet 19
vaccine
for the same reason that we've always
required vaccinations of students
whether it's for measles or mumps
or meningitis and it's to keep the
community safe
northeastern reopened last fall but with
frequent covet testing
social distancing protocols and limited
in-person classes
you never know if someone has um
coronavirus so
it's just like that that whole issue of
like i want to meet new people i want to
get into my new college environment but
is it safe to do so yet i'd say that was
the biggest stressor
of like going to college this year which
was definitely unique for
our class cole claire cuzio is a
freshman
and says his experience has been
anything but normal he works part-time
as an emt
treating covet patients up close so he
jumped at the opportunity to get
vaccinated
definitely like when i saw that i had an
opportunity to get an appointment i took
the first available like
there was no question in my mind he's
even been volunteering to help get
people vaccinated
and appeared in a school-produced psa if
i could carry vaccines with me and just
walk around giving them to people it's
that easy
like many of the other schools mandating
the vaccine northeastern says it will
allow for medical and religious
exemptions
but armini says that making this
announcement early will allow vaccine
hesitant students to make other plans
because they won't be allowed on campus
i mean we hope it doesn't
come to that we hope that over the
summer um
you know anyone who may have some
vaccine hesitancy
that that sort of dissipates over time
one thing that we always find
with students is that peer-to-peer is
very powerful so if their friends
are being vaccinated and they're
enthusiastic about it that helps a lot
other colleges are hoping they can reach
herd immunity without a mandate
texas a m and virginia tech believe the
requirements conflict with federal law
because the fda has only allowed the
emergency use of the vaccines
i think a lot of it's just becoming very
politically charged this
debate around vaccine passports by
getting a vaccine
you're allowed to do certain things and
by not getting it you're left out of
those things
so places like florida arizona texas
utah specifically says that public
higher ed institutions are not allowed
to
require vaccination of students faculty
and staff in order to be on campus
the country's largest university systems
the university of california
and california state university recently
announced they intend to require
vaccinations for the more than a million
students and faculty
but say the timing of a more formal
mandate will depend on when the fda
gives full authorization to one or more
of the vaccines
it could come before or after classes
start
many schools aren't wasting any time
they've launched vaccination blitzes and
public health campaigns to get students
immunized before they leave for the
summer
protecting the pack we're all getting
tested regularly making sure to fill out
our daily wellness checks
last week cornell university in ithaca
new york held a pop-up vaccination event
on campus that provided modernist shots
to students
the school says that nearly 50 percent
of the current on-campus population is
already vaccinated
senior jaydo vadiya says she's relieved
to see more and more of her classmates
vaccinated
so i'm fully vaccinated as are many of
the cornell students
everybody is very eager to get
vaccinated you know college life
you only get to have it really once in
your life and you know coven 19 kind of
interrupted that for us and these are
years that
we don't really get back so i think
we're all just really eager and willing
to take whatever actions that will
help us be able to return back to that
experience